federal investigators are searching for
suspects in an Internet fraud case that
nearly anyone who's received a
suspicious email will recognize these
six fugitives are thought to be in the
u.s. 80 people in all most of them from
Nigeria face charges after a three year
investigation at least 11 people total
were arrested yesterday in Southern
California they're charged with money
laundering fraud and identity theft
prosecutors say millions of dollars were
stolen from unsuspecting people online
Jamie yuccas is tracking the
investigation Jamie these scammers have
become much more sophisticated in recent
years who are the targets of this
alleged scam well prosecutors say the
defendants preyed on everyone from
people looking for romance to businesses
and the elderly the investigation began
in 2016 with a single bank account and
one victim it grew to include dozens of
victims in the US and around the world
some who lost hundreds of thousands of
dollars the common thread is that all of
these schemes involve the internet to
defraud victims federal authorities took
11 defendants into custody near Los
Angeles Thursday as part of what they
say is a highly sophisticated crime ring
according to a 252 count indictment 80
defendants are accused of hacking email
accounts to convince businesses and
individuals to make bogus payments the
suspects would then funnel that money to
Nigeria the money launderers routinely
went as far as registering fictitious
business names with LA County so they
can open bank accounts and the
fictitious business names prosecutors
say the alleged thieves stole six
million dollars and tried to make off
with another forty million the suspects
also allegedly used online romance scams
similar to the one that debbie
montgomery johnson fell victim to in
2010 I talked him a few times I mean we
messaged every day the widowed mother of
four thought she was communicating with
a British businessman only to find out
it was a Nigerian conman she says she
lost much of her life savings federal
officials have warned about the rise and
online fraud in public service
announcements like this one mr. Jacobs
just transferred the money
whatever should project don't be that
guy
their hope now is this latest bust will
send a strong message to criminals
thinking of preying on innocent people
this case is part of our ongoing efforts
to protect Americans from fraudulent
schemes if convicted all the defendants
could face decades in prison in the days
ahead federal authorities will be
working with their foreign counterparts
in nine countries to apprehend nearly 60
additional suspects Tony Jamie back here
in this country what should people look
out for to avoid getting scammed like
this that's a good question the FBI is
reminding Americans that they should
never send money to someone they don't
know have not met and really have no
reason to trust and to never provide
bank account information they also urge
people to be cautious of urgent demands
for money Tony thanks scary stuff Thank
You Jamie